the United States has worked in lockstep
with our allies and partners around the
world to make sure you the Ukrainian
people are in the strongest possible
position to defend their Nation their
families and against the brutal the
truly brutal aggression of Russia I
haven't seen the likes of this in a long
time
the United States and Europe are fully
United
this morning
I had a long conversation with our NATO
allies German Chancellor Schultz friends
president macron prime minister Sanuk
and the Italian Prime Minister Maloney
uh to continue our close coordination
and our full support of Ukraine because
you all know I've been saying this for a
long time the expectation of the part of
Russia is we're going to break up we're
not going to stay United but we are
fully thoroughly totally United
with spring approaching Ukrainian forces
are working to defend the territory they
hold and preparing for additional
counter offenses
to liberate their land they need to be
able to counter Russia's evolving
tactics and strategy on the battlefield
in the very near term
they need to improve their ability to
maneuver an open Terrain
and they need an enduring capability to
deter and defend against Russian
aggression over the long term
the Secretary of State the secretary of
the uh of the military behind me are
they they've been deeply deeply involved
in this this whole effort armored
capability as general Austin will tell
you to speak uh
is has been has been critical that's why
the United States has committed hundreds
of armored fighting vehicles to date
including more than 500 as part of the
assistance package we announced last
Friday
and today today I'm announcing that the
United States will be sending 31 Abram
tanks to Ukraine the equivalent of one
Ukrainian Battalion secretary Austin has
recommended this step because it will
enhance the Ukraine's capacity to defend
its territory and Achieve his strategic
objectives the Abrams tanks are the most
capable tanks in the world they're also
extremely complex to operate and
maintain
so we're also giving Ukraine the parts
and equipment necessary to effectively
sustain these tanks on the battlefield
when we begin we'll begin to train the
Ukrainian troops on these issues of
sustainment logistics and maintenance
soon as possible
delivering these tanks to the field is
going to take time
time that we'll see we'll use to make
sure the ukrainians are fully prepared
to integrate the Abram tanks into their
defenses
we're also closely coordinated this
announcement with our allies
the American contribution will be joined
by an additional announcement including
that will be will be readily available
and more easily integrated for use in
the battlefield in the coming weeks and
months from other countries I'm grateful
that Chancellor Schultz for providing
German Leopard two tanks and will lead
an effort to organize a European
contribution of two tank battalions for
Ukraine I want to thank the chancellor
for his leadership and his steadfast
commitment to our Collective efforts to
support Ukraine
Germany has really stepped up the
chancellor has been a strong strong
voice for Unity a close friend and for
the level of effort we're going to
continue
supporting Ukraine's ability to fight
off Russian aggression to defend its
sovereignty and territorial Integrity is
a worldwide commitment I just looked a
worldwide commitment last week Germany
in Germany secretary Austin convened
Ukraine defense contact group for the
eighth time this group is made up of
some 50 Nations 50 Nations each making
significant contribution of their own to
Ukraine's integrity
he's fully committed to making Ukraine
remain strong and independent and able
to defend itself against Russian threats
and violence
I want to thank every member of that
Coalition for continuing to step up
the UK the United Kingdom recently
announced that it's donating Challenger
two tanks to Ukraine France is
contributing AMX 10s armored inviting
vehicles
in addition to the leopard tanks the
Germany like the United States is also
Germany is also sending a pet a patriot
missile battery the Netherlands is
donating to Patriot missile and
launchers France Canada the UK Slovakia
and Norway and others have all donated
critical air defense systems to help
secure Ukrainian skies and save the
lives of innocent civilians who are
literally the target the target of
Russia's aggression
Poland is sending armored vehicles
Sweden is donating infantry fighting
Vehicles Italy is giving artillery
Denmark and Estonia are sending
howitzers Latvia is providing more
Stinger missiles lithuanians providing
anti-aircraft guns and Finland recently
announced its largest package of
security assistance to date you may
remember what was asked a while ago what
I think was going to happen and I said
probably but Putin no he thought that
he's going to end up with a
fiddalization of Europe we've got the
natoization of Finland he's gotten
something that he never intended
together with our allies and partners
we've sent more than 3 000 armored
vehicles
more than 8 000 artillery systems more
than two million rounds of artillery
ammunition and more than 50 Advanced
multi-launch rocket systems and I ship
in air defense systems all to help
counter Ukraine's brutal aggression
that's happening because of Russia
and look today's announcement Builds on
the hard work and commitment from
countries around the world led by the
United States of America to help Ukraine
defend its sovereignty in its
territorial integrity
that's what this is about helping
Ukraine defend and protect Ukrainian
land it is not an offensive threat to
Russia we are there is no offensive
threat to Russia if Russia troops return
to Russia they'll be there for the this
where they belong this war would be over
today
that's what we all want an end of this
war
in just and Lasting terms
you know our teams do not permit One
Nation we're not going to allow one
nation to steal the neighbor's territory
by force
our terms that preserve Russia's
Sovereign Ukrainian sovereignty and
territorial integrity and honor the U.N
Charter that's our they're the terms
we're working on
and you know these are these are the
terms we all signed up for and 143
Nations voted for in the United Nations
General Assembly last October
so the United States standing shoulder
to shoulder of allies and partners is
going to continue to do all we can to
support Ukraine
Putin expected Europe and the United
States to weaken our resolve he expected
our support for Ukraine to crumble with
time he was wrong
he was wrong he was wrong from the
beginning he continues to be wrong we
are united America is United and so is
the world
and we approached the one-year Mark as
we do of the Russian full-scale invasion
Ukraine we remain United and determined
as ever and our conviction and our cause
these tanks are further evidence of our
enduring unflagging commitment to
Ukraine and our confidence in the skill
of the Ukrainian forces
as I told president zielinski when he
was here and today is his birthday by
the way
in December we're with you for as long
as it takes Mr President
ukrainians are fighting an age-old
battle against aggression and domination
it's a battle Americans have fought
proudly time and again
and it's a battle we're going to make
sure the ukrainians are well equipped to
fight as well this is about freedom
freedom for Ukraine
Freedom everywhere it's about the kind
of world we want to live in the world we
want to leave to our children
so may God protect the brave Ukrainian
Defenders of their country and keep the
flame of Liberty Burning Brightly as we
can thank you Mr President why are you
taking this decision now
Germany forced you to change your mind
on sending tanks
targeted enforce me to change your mind
we wanted to make sure we're all
together as we're going to do all and
that's what we're doing right now thank
you Mr President any response to the
Pence disclosures of classified
documents